lawmakers they're starting to learn more
about exactly what happened yesterday in
paris that's right mark lawmakers day
attending a closed-door briefing to
learn more details not only what the
French knew about the suspects but also
with the United States might have known
about these specific suspects the names
have been scrubbed within us
intelligence databases were being told
by lawmakers familiar with the situation
and there's some real concerns expressed
by some of the lawmakers leaving that
meeting this morning mark that they're
worried about the tactics here them the
fact that a soft target was selected
there in Paris by these terrorists and
they're worried about some sort of
replay here and also the notion that
perhaps if these individuals were
trained overseas perhaps Syria and Iraq
and then came back to France could the
same thing happen here with American
citizens who have gone abroad to those
countries as well question marks out
there in the part on the minds of some
lawmakers here worried about US security
going forward and Peter I mentioned the
attack weighing on that fight over
Homeland Security funding of course
that's in the middle of a political back
and forth on the hill what's going on
there well you recall at the end of last
year the government of the agreement to
fund the government through most of 20
2015 one agency was not included in that
and that's the Department of Homeland
Security only funded and through the end
of next month the reason for that is
Republicans starting next week are going
to push for new funding for the agency
but they're going to tie to that an
effort to roll back the president's
immigration executive actions and the
question being posed now in light of
Paris is this the right time to put
Department of Homeland Security funding
in doubt Speaker Boehner asked about
that today I don't believe that the
funding of the department is in fact at
risk what is at risk is the rule of law
and the sanctity of America's
Constitution the president has taken
actions that are beyond the scope of his
ability and the Congress cannot just sit
here and look the other way we have to
take action and we will so to suit two
different issues here mark of course the
Paris tragedy the fight over immigration
in this country but they are now linked
now politically this fight over funding
is going to play out next week and it
could get
Glee don't be surprised here Democrats
and the White House really go after
Republicans for putting this funding in
doubt because the immigration issue